i just changed the stream title to a
smiley face
oh tagi's still challenging me
is taki still here i could play tagi
and otagi wanted me to keep playing
people tagi's been the longest
challenger too
let's play a bird because the bird is a
word
i don't know if tony's still here oh
blind
wait where's my blindfold yeah i usually
play against laggy blind i have um
it's a headband i got this for tennis
usually
oh this is really weird
it like squeezes my face i can't see
anything though
i can't really like even open man
this is uncomfortable but i could play
like this
um i feel like roger feather now
man okay i'll play blind
okay i think we're good
bishop e2 okay beautiful aha my mic
i didn't see the mic was in my face
four minutes two seconds okay
four minutes 32 seconds okay so i'm only
down like
25 seconds now
f6 f6
uh i'll play another three knight f3
okay
i haven't played blindfold in a while
bishop g4
bishop g4 i'll play e3
e3
if people want to see more blindfold
content i had a
three hour blindfold queen odds match
against tagi
it's on my youtube channel you can
probably just search for toggy
queen d7 uh i'll play bishop b5
bishop b5
i forgot to check if there's increments
but
i'll just move quickly bishop takes it
takes c6
queen takes c6 knight c3 i'm going to
stay flexible like which side to castle
so he still has a pawn on f6
and oh e5
and talk he's playing well play h3 h3
so the bishop moves back like f5 or h5 i
play g4
if vision moves to a bishop takes on f3
i take with queen
i feel like toggy's gotten better since
last time we played f3
queen takes e4 okay he plays e4
i can play queen oh i can play queen h5
queen
[Music]
because g5 is now hanging
i could pre-move queen d5 g6
queen takes d5
takes d5 hoppity hoppity hoppity hoppity
hop
what what
takes d5 oh i took on d5 and then he
hopped
okay okay i got it okay let's um
[Music]
let's take on f6
with the knight knight takes f6
so he still hasn't light on g8
oh wait this is really good i think wait
wait a minute d2's attacked what's
happening hottie hop
hoppity hoppity hoppity hop
okay oh oh he saved everything
can i play i could play knight g4 g4
knight takes g4 and now
uh i'll just take with pawn takes g4
so i have i'm up a bunch of pawns
i'm going to win each seven two
i still have all eight pawns
[Music]
on g8 king on d7 okay life is pretty
good here
bishop e7 bishop e7
could play um rook h7
brick h7 threatening
bishop f6 i guess i think
okay just gotta stay focused i think my
pawns are on
where are my pawns i'll play g5
g5 so a2 b3 c2 d2 e3
f4 g5 and i think half upon g2
what v6 b6
um kings on e8
we'll play bishop e5 bishop e5
so now i'm threatening to take on c7
i think bishop d6
c takes d6 okay so we prove that um
we'll play rook
i want to keep the rook let's play king
b2 let's walk the king all the way
along the long diagonal
so he has all his pawns on the sixth
rank i think a6 b6
etc
yeah box completely a bit stuck
uh king d4 king d4
brick f5 one minute sometime
look f5
wait does he have a pawn on e4 still
king takes you he did okay i forgot
about that pawn
until i remembered
d5 check oh
okay king d4 king b4 g4 coming maybe
b5 what b5 uh g4
g4 so i'm gonna win man i still have all
your pawns f8
it's so nice king d5 king takes d5
rook e8 uh
e4 e4
a5
[Music]
uh
where are all my pawns rook a7
a takes b3 ab3 a takes
how much time do i have also where is
black's rook rook e8
king takes e8 uh f5 f5
g takes f5 g king f7
ah king e5
f6 king f7 king f5
i don't know if i'm flagging g8 g6
king f8
b takes e3 f7 check
king f6 c yes
okay oh i assume the king went to f8
let's go oh my eyes let's go
oh i had 28 seconds oh there's no
increments
i heard the time warning thing and i got
scared
yeah really that really messed up my
eyes
oh tiger's winning score oh now we're
tied 16 all
yeah tagi uh got the better of me in our
previous blindfold games king g8
why c4 i forgot where my d pawn was
i i tried playing d4 i forgot my pawn
was already on d4
i think and then when i played c4
i was vaguely aware that there's on
passant
and what i wanted to do here
it's hard because you sometimes panic
and blindfold
oh i played a relatively clean game hey
um let me turn off this thing
what i wanted to do here is this and
then mate but this is stalemate
so c4 turned out to be really nice
because it gave back
a legal move in this position
and then i think after i played f7 i
pre-moved king f6
um so it would have been annoying if
this was played
and then i would have had to promote
the other thing though when typing the
moves
uh promoting to a queen is sometimes
weird
so it was nice to create a situation
where
i could pondermate and not need to
promote to a queen
what kind of tea i was not drinking tea
i was drinking
water which i guess is flavorless tea
i was drinking this thing which is
some stuff i found from whole foods
but yeah thanks for the game toggy that
was a good fight toggy put up resistance
um i completely forgot this pawn existed